PROFESSOR: So today
was the lecture
on scripting and hosting.
It's the end of day three.
This is probably the lecture
that I was the most prepared
for in terms of practice ahead
of time, ahead of this class.
Because it's kind of
what George and I do
for most of the
production process
that happens for
Science Out Loud.
So whenever we work
with our students
in the individual
seasons, this is basically
what we do with them, just
a little bit more formalized
and for a longer period of time.
It is so hard to
teach good hosting
because it's one of those
things that you can sit and read
about.
And you can watch a
bunch of case studies.
And it just doesn't matter until
you try to adopt it yourself.
I had planned all this material
where it would be like,
there were all these
videos of various hosts.
And it's going to be sort of
a similar exercise to day one,
to all those YouTube videos
where it would go through
and they would write some of
the qualities that they liked
and try to see what they wanted
to take on for themselves.
But we just totally scrapped it.
And I think, honestly, it
was much better that we did.
The hosting thing is hard in
helping the students really
be comfortable with their own
voice and their own persona
on screen.
It's really important.
So I don't want to
distract from that at all.
One of the students wanted
to minimize her presence
on screen.
I don't want the students
here to sell themselves
short on the power that they
have as a practitioner of some
of the science and engineering
to default to a type of video
that a lot of other
people can make.
These students are
not the best hosts.
Finding like a Neil
deGrasse Tyson at MIT,
you can't bank on that.
And I don't mean
that in a mean way.
Perhaps I should rephrase this.
Maybe they can cut this out.
It is an imprudent
thing to assume
that we're going to find
the next Bill Nye at MIT.
We can't expect the students
to become like Hank Green
and to make the next SciShow.
That's an unfair
expectation to have.
But the value proposition
that they offer here,
which I think is
so powerful, which
I think is the most
important thing,
that someone like Michael
Stevens on Vsauce can't do,
and SciShow can't do, is
that they are the scientists.
They are the people who
worked in the industry.
They are the actual
Naval engineers.
That is something,
for me, personally
is so important to highlight.
So to make themselves evident,
I think, is really important.
To make themselves the hosts,
to make themselves visible,
to make their persona and
their actual personal stories
part of the video, I
think, is important.
Whether you're in front of the
camera, or you're on a stage,
or you're on a
podium giving a talk,
the habit of falling back
into this monotonous robotic
or perceived persona that
you think you have to take on
totally happens all the time.
So I think it's
a relevant lesson
that people can take with
them after this class is over.
I'm definitely
rambling at this point.
Maybe it's because George did
most of the talking today.
But I think it went OK.